happy new year yeah yeah
[Laughter]
is it is it is it well i mean it is the
new year
it is it is a new year um
i hope it's going to be happier um
uh it's it's a bizarre time in our lives
so
it's you know when somebody says happy
new year you go
how do you mean that
what do you mean
look i don't take that talk from anybody
right right
not quite the uh not quite the utopia of
the promise of the
uh federation not quite not quite there
yet not quite
not quite you know so um
with agent revelation i want to ask you
know you have done a lot of sci-fi we
know you a lot from
from uh all of that work that you've
done what makes a compelling sci-fi
excuse me a compelling sci-fi story to
you
um a compelling sci-fi story is a story
that has
uh that's exciting first of all things
you know things that that are very
inventive
uh in terms of you know not necessarily
cgi
but what the director or the writer
envisions you know um are the future to
be
um and a great story
uh but also a story that is relevant to
our times
because and it doesn't have to it
doesn't have to mirror
what's happening but it may just mirror
you know
our are um you know who we are as a
people where we're going
you know that kind of thing um
the old sci-fi shows outer limits and um
um twilight zone we're all about
us you know who we are
and i always think that that's that's
really compelling i mean i love
star wars um for one reason and not
not one reason but for a lot of reasons
is that
it was uh you know the guy the bad guy
wore black
and the um and the the good guys were
you know
the the other guys you know i mean you
could there's
evil and good and it's a constant battle
and yeah you could identify with that
um there's quite a bit of green screen
work in uh
in this film do you find that that's
something that helps
you know the idea that you get to
imagine
what's happening around you is that
theatrical
is that something that helps you kind of
uh get into a mode of a character
not not at all not at all especially
especially these days
because there's so much green screen in
science fiction that you know and we
didn't do
we didn't do as much green screen as
they do now but but there was a lot of
it
uh in terms of uh when we were on the
holodeck
or when we talked to people on the view
screen
that was all green screen we didn't even
we didn't know who the people you know
what they looked like
or anything you know so
so it really is kind of all the same um
i think i remember 95 i did a show that
was
all green screen there was a chair in
the center of this
of this set and the rest of it was just
all green screen
yeah and but if you have other actors to
relate to
um then that's who you relate to you
know yeah you don't really
you don't really know or or can even
imagine what the
what the set's gonna look like you just
relate to the other actors
and the editors and the director they
put all that other stuff in so
people always talk about how star trek
uh predicted the future
technology and here we are it's kind of
kind of like on these zoom calls you've
got your own like holodeck right now
oh yeah i mean we had ipads
um before they were you know even
dreamed of i guess you know
literally we had pads with everything on
it that we can
do with little things and and go on so
so yeah the the tech is
but the good thing about star trek is
that they've always done
is that they've consulted the scientists
they didn't just
dream up something and kind of go oh i
guess that's the way it's gonna i mean
they really
they really talked to scientists and
they had a relationship with a lot of
different like there was there's one
part where
the ship goes into war and it elongates
you know and then goes into war and i
actually talked to the
to the special effects guy and i said
you know is that really what happens and
he goes
oh yeah you know they they've surmised
scientists
that when you do that that's what
happens to the
to your perception and i go really
because oh yeah
you know this is not just something made
up you know so
and it became iconic yep
now we know that you've been talking
about um
the idea of a wharf spin-off series
we've got season one of picard
already done and a lot of people want to
see you
as a guest on there it's an event
whenever one of the
the tng members get to be on the show
how close are we to seeing that
uh you know that's a question that you
have to put to them because
i i have not been asked and so
um i i don't know i i wish i could tell
you but i just don't know
uh like i said um it was um
i don't know if it was much of a secret
when jonathan and marina were on
but um but they have not asked me and so
i just kind of
go on with my life you know
but you know in in science fiction you
never say never
you just of course yeah um
evan from the show has talked about how
he would love to see wharf
on uh to to kind of like
bring back that romulan klingon
relationship but in the new era that
they're doing there
what in your imagination what would worf
be doing
beyond what we know from what we've seen
them on tv already
well you know that i wrote this script
and
it's basically my idea of what
would be doing basically he's trying to
keep uh the klingon empire from dying
so he has gone back and forth between
starfleet and the klingon empire and so
he decided he's not going to be
tied to either he's going to work
for the betterment of of of both
cultures
and to that end he is trying to keep the
klingon
empire from from being destroyed uh
because they have
uh as as with the russians you know the
russians
you know or the romans you know their
their system was
was um destroyed because they had so
many places that they had to keep going
you know they had the middle east you
know they had england they had all these
places that they had conquered
that they have to send resources
and money and and soldiers to keep it
going and it destroyed their empire and
so that's what's happening
klingon empire is that that's cool
yeah and so uh my idea is that
warp goes to the high council and says
look
you know yeah we can die with a weapon
in our hand and that'll be the end of us
or we can be warriors and and adapt and
and prolong and have a more glorious
you know future and they said well how
do you want to do that said well we have
to go out to
all these worlds that we conquered and
basically
make friends with them we have to
so we don't have to to spend so many
resources
which means we have their allies we have
to if they want independence
give them independence and the high
council says yeah well
if that's what you want to do then
you're the one that has to go do that
and so the wharf is on a ship and he's
going every
every episode he's into he's gone to a
new world
to to say hey look you know we're
changing we want to bring you into the
fold we don't want to conquer you we
want to let you go
and of course that just is wrought with
danger
so the appetite is there the appetite is
there for this
don't you think yeah um
but it is a really interesting
[Music]
world the star trek world is very
interesting i don't understand it but
you know they have their their ideas and
they have their
um their plans and you know
i would think that that was an easy sell
you know like oh of course
you know the script is written the
character is there
everything is you know but um
they have other plans for star trek and
i don't know if it includes me so
we'll see i was wondering you know with
us
getting closer and closer to um
the idea of commercial space flight
people being able to actually
get out there now with spacex would you
sign up
are you interested in getting out there
and actually you know seeing the earth
from the stars sort of thing
uh no i'm not a
i'm not a chicken but the one thing that
is
it is that is very clear
is that it's very dangerous
you know it's not it's not like
a sunday drive and until it gets to be
like a sunday drive
i'll just look at pictures you know
look at it and that's enough fair
fair well sir thank you so much for your
time
i'm looking i'm looking forward to
seeing what the future has in store and
i'm sure millions of others are uh for
wharf so we'll um
yeah yeah i i i like i'd like for them
to
to at least entertain the idea and and
just go
i mean because there's so much out there
there's so much
um there's so many platforms and so many
ways to go that
that it seems to be for us for you and
me
it seems to be an easy sell but maybe
not for them
so um so we'll see but otherwise you
know like
i was very happy with the script i wrote
and so if nothing happens with it
it's it's one of those things that i
that i was very happy with and i and
uh i'm proud that i was able to do it so
right on all right thank you thank you
for your time one question before we
i just want to know where you are
located michael sorry
i'm the producer um
where am i located yeah just for a
locator key for our segment
uh i'm in orange county um a place
uh called ladera ranch okay
and then maybe just just just so we have
um just one more thing for your new
film could you just tell us sort of you
know just pump up the people why they
should get excited for why they should
watch it that was my only question
carlos if you want to just
ask that yeah absolutely for a lot of
reasons
i think that the um the technology
is is amazing um
because of the the where it's situated
in
in sort of the movie world um he had to
rely
on story and he had to rely on um
you know having a you know
good actors who can you know pull off
this thing with
with cgi is what they're doing and um
the re i only think i could say is that
the reason i enjoyed it or the reason i
even chose to do it
was because it is a good story and the
character is a is a great character
um he has depth he is
a kind of a tortured soul which
i love to play you know
and i think that um
from from where it started um
to where it ends i think it's it it
leaves itself open for
for sequels uh which is always a good
thing
um and the main thing is it's exciting
you know it's it's
it's a it has all the elements of uh
of a great movie and uh and that that's
what the main thing that drew me to it
so
uh it would be great for the
for the fans people that have seen it
you know already
uh really like it a lot and that's that
feels good
so uh we just we're just hoping to keep
that going
you